[Musique]
port du masque a été rendue obligatoire
des marquages ont été installés au sol
et sur les sièges pour faire respecter
la distanciation sociale des rhamna
quelque 280 passagers au lieu de 800 en
temps normal
[Musique]
bonjour mesdames
mother
fraude bien emporter un autre tu dois
aussi on va pouvoir toucher parce qu'il
ya un an m
encore plus dur de vous et ça me frustre
et vu qu'on va faire quoi on est avec
nos copains qui ne va pas pouvoir jouer
avec eux
[Musique]
mais finalement des volumes anjali amour
se connaître la grille m'a dit non au
diamant et où les laumes
oh
elle
[Musique]
dans le quartier se vide a bloqué la
mèche à ceux d'apple a vraiment super
d'être à l'arrivée des normes à cause de
l'avenir ne tiendrait pas
[Musique]
me
à
[Musique]
m
au match de foot c'est comme la mairie
vers cela
[Musique]
ça
vincenzo cance forfour 10 6% toughcase
1,6 visible celle des urines de richard
berry match et de grippe mauvaise pente
avec
[Musique]